a summer Saturday in the 2020 Democratic
candidates are out on the campaign trail
this weekend ahead of next week's debate
this is the latest Fox News poll showing
president from trailing Joe Biden by 10
percentage points with the former vice
president taking 49% of the vote
head-to-head against the president the
election were held today with that we
bring in Michael moles host of the aptly
named Michael knows show show heard on
whatever podcast platform you desire
around the world
10 points that's not a good that's not a
good sign
I heard the president wasn't too happy
about you think we have it we have the
president's response I think yep they're
like we'll put it up fair to say he
wasn't happy here it is the polls have
always been terrible to me they had me
losing big to crooked Hillary have me
down to sleep ego even considering then
he goes on to list all of his
accomplishments that's true I think we
down down by 10 with the economy as good
as it is not not great I just don't buy
it is the issue I mean there was a month
or two ago there were all of those polls
that showed that head-to-head Cory
Booker was beating Donald Trump if you
think Cory Booker is going to beat
Donald Trump I've got a bridge in
Brooklyn to sell you I think if the
election were held today Donald Trump
would win 57 States he's got two real
vulnerabilities he's got the economy if
the economy falters obviously that's
gonna be trouble and he's got
immigration this was a central issue of
his campaign and he got great news this
week he actually got great news on two
fronts 2016 was about judges and
immigration and he got great news on
immigration from the judges that he
appointed left 5-4 decision yeah say he
can finally build some new wall after
that CVP
it didn't it did not bode well for him
when there was the headline not one mile
not one inch of new wall has been built
this is a real issue because President
Trump has fulfilled a lot of his
campaign promises but this was a central
issue if he can't build one inch of wall
before 2020 if he doesn't have a path
forward I think that's going to weaken
some support for him but fortunately it
looks as though we may get a hundred
miles and maybe not the near future but
there's a path forward you don't think
it matters who he's running is is what
I'm getting from you not exactly I mean
of all of these candidates the question
you have to ask is which one is actually
going to beat him you could have any
sort of polls
you know Joe Biden wins 80% of the vote
but do we really think the Joe Biden if
he manages to even get his Walker out
and get along the campaign in fair in
fairness to Biden look at look at where
he stands right now he's almost double
Bernie Sanders in the Real Clear
Politics average we have our own pulling
out in terms of where where he is as
well
everyone said hey Carla Harris her
attack is gonna knock him off etc that
hasn't happened we're very early in
right we've had one debate we have 11
more of these debates coming up she got
a pretty good swing in on Joe Biden then
and he just seems too old he doesn't
seem to have the stamina I think Barack
Obama was pretty wise not to endorse him
early on and I think that tells us is
there a reason for caution among
Republicans and among Trump supporters
look this time four years ago everyone
was saying Donald Trump's too crazy he's
too far right he's too bombastic he
annoys too many people he'll never be
elected president he's never going he
was number one in the polls and he came
out on top
one thing you learn especially in the
age of Trump is never say never write
those things I'm not saying he doesn't
have any vulnerabilities but he has
somehow like a wizard made his opponents
oppose all of the things Americans
cherish there was that poll that just
came out from Gallup that immigration is
the number one issue for Americans
another poll showed that law enforcement
is the third most trusted institution in
the United States below small business
and the military you at now have
Democrats running on open borders
running against law enforcement they're
running against the American flag that
is not a good look to win over middle
America we know from the Trump campaign
that whoever ends up with the Democratic
nomination they're gonna brand as a
socialist who's pro-abortion and Pro
open borders that's the playbook no
matter who it is looking in terms of who
it's going to be we have the debate
cards coming up for Tuesday and
Wednesday night in Detroit anything
stand out to you in this as we look at
Tuesday night well what you're seeing I
mean the the candidates to watch
obviously or Elizabeth Warren and Kamala
Harris Elizabeth Warren has done a
pretty good job of slow and slowly and
steadily coming up she's got a plan for
everything she's got a plan for
everything it happens to be Bernie
Sanders is planned because he
transformed that party I think she's the
one to watch I think she's she's crafty
she appeals to the establish
wing and to the progressive wing and she
actually coos is this elizabeth warren's
debate in the way that calm well harris
was last time around that's up to
elizabeth warren if it is but it
certainly has the opportunity if we put
that fullscreen up again of the second
debate night this is wednesday night you
might call it the main card because
you've got booker there you've got biden
there you also have Kamala Harris there
if Biden survives this and he comes out
swinging as he says he will does your
opinion change yes Biden has had some
endurance and some stability so far even
though we're very early on I think
really the one to watch here is Cory
Booker the question is if if it the
situation had been reversed in Booker
were the one on stage at the main debate
last time could he have gotten the the
racial slug in at Joe Biden that Kamala
Harris he did a couple of times he
basically called Biden a racist but can
he do it to his face can he get it right
we can he really land that punch we'll
see I think it's it's going to be an
opportunity for him
it may be do-or-die for Cory Booker
because he's been languishing toward the
bottom of the polls for months and
months now yeah he said he has been and
he was evidently offering money to
charity to shave people's heads a couple
of days ago I don't know if you saw that
but he it did go viral on Twitter so
there is that Michael good to see is
always appreciate it gonna check back in
with you